Ben Simmons of the Philadelphia 76ers
are you a football fan Ben fan now oh
yeah what were you before you went to
Philadelphia I wasn't really a football
fan I was just you know watch games from
time to time but I never really got into
it but when you were watching so in
Australia how big is football they're
not very big at OU soccer rugby
yes trailing football it says the number
one sport
how would you fare did you play that
yeah I played when I was around 14
how good were you I was pretty good I
just wasn't you know one of the in love
with the game all right let me get to a
couple of questions here what's your
official position on the 76ers point
guard oh you know I go into four
sometimes when TJ comes in and mix it up
but do you want to you want to be
considered a point guard yeah I am a
point guard okay I'm looking at the
program it lists you as a guard an
afford you're a - here do you consider
yourself a rookie technically I am but I
mean I never walk into a game thinking
I'm a rookie I didn't go in thinking you
know I want to win a game and I'm one of
the best players in the quartet okay but
what did you learn by not playing last
year just learning the game the pace of
the game different ways to score and
defend players and read certain
situations so I think that year
definitely helped do you feel like you
have a target on your back anywhere near
or similar to Lonzo ball that people
want a piece of you I just come out and
play
I don't worry about you know what people
are saying on social media or because
things are just gonna happen if you you
know stick to the stick to the route
that you've been given that work hard or
just play do you understand what Lonzo
balls going through at all
no I have no idea I mean being a top
pick and then having that pressure on
you to some extent I understand but
there's a lot of guy you know gunning
for him and that's not easy coming in
the first year but also makes you a
better player but your dad doesn't get
involved why I mean this is my business
so you know he knows I can handle myself
there's a new speech for me that's cool
give people an idea of how good your dad
was in Australia
I used the legend back back in Australia
they played for five position was a
beast defensively and then under the rim
you know you don't get everything so
he's one of those players very
aggressive very physical not exactly
what I what I am a much different place
stuff he's been Simmons of the 76ers
please refer to him as a point guard how
much of a comedian is Jo Ellen beat he's
funny every day is something new with
him every day
well there's Twitter Instagram or just
making jokes in person he's goofy man
and and and not a friend goofy in a good
way but he's not afraid to call out guys
oh definitely not
he knows how much work he's put in so
he's not scared to you know say
something what are the expectations that
you have this season what would be a
good season for you individually he
seems to play us well but but stat-wise
what do you look at numbers wise I know
you want you want wins how do you know
you've had a good game when we have all
right but how important is a
triple-double to you every night is that
a goal helps win games that make the
team you know get to the playoffs and
I'm all for it but if that's not what's
gonna get the team to the playoffs and I
don't want give me your official height
and weight because you look like you're
seven feet tall then
I feel like 611 235 okay but but you
could be seven feet tall with your shoes
on right yeah Wow seven foot point
during unbelievable are you binge do
binge watch TV no no I watch too much TV
what do you watch movies I watched like
TV shows like South Park Bauer and get
into like TV TV are you a soap opera fan
no I got bad information says you're a
soap opera fan no all right I'm gonna
have to fire that guy who came up with
that information
good luck are you guarding Harden
tonight the scouting report is he's
going to shoot an awful lot oh
definitely yeah he's also great
hey have fun thanks for joining us good
luck this season we appreciate your time
oh thank you all right that's Ben
Simmons 76ers 7-foot point guard for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]